here is Gen Saki and as you know she is
now an MSNBC contributor she went from
being the chief paid liar at the White
House and then she just took a job in
journalism just like journalism just
like that she now works for MSNBC and
here she is saying that the Democrats
there was nothing they could have done
about inflation just because they're in
charge of everything they couldn't have
done anything I mean what do you want
from these people speaking of that
environment Jen I mean when you look at
the economy and you look at inflation it
consistently raises the top issue to
voters and Republicans when you ask
those folks who say that they're
consistently saying they're going to
vote Republican by pretty lopsided
margins is there anything Democrats
could have done was there a missed
opportunity here for Democrats to not
face that kind of the headwind look on
inflation it's a global issue it's
happening around the world I think
there's not a lot Democrats could have
done to change that reality
complete nonsense complete nonsense I'm
going to give you some stats in a moment
but just if you took econ 101 in college
maybe not even in college did you learn
anything about basic math or checks and
balances or the red and the black uh
when you were in high school perhaps How
about if when Joe Biden came in he said
you know we're going to cut taxes for
everybody so that the economy can get
going you know we've been going through
this coveted thing it's been a tough
thing we want businesses to feel like
they have a little more money in their
pocket so they can spend a little bit
more money so that they can hopefully
hire more that gets more people out and
about and shopping and doing things and
then the economy kind of chugs along
sort of like it did under that Donald
Trump guy that would have been one thing
but I don't want to just give you my
crazy theories on the economy how about
we give you actual numbers on what the
Democrats did to basically tank the
economy and cause inflation to go up and
uh contrary to what Joe Biden said not
half the debt I mean unbelievable that
he lied about that uh here's some info
from visual capitalist in 2021 the U US
government spent 6.8 trillion on various
expenditures and government-aided
programs so the government spent get it
again
6.8 trillion that's an awful lot of
money a lot of zeros there on government
programs so they took money from you
right from the taxpayer and then they
decided to do whatever they wanted to do
with it and often it is completely
nonsensical stuff or we you know we're
bombing somebody or whatever it might be
or it's handouts that then keep people
in poverty you get the rest of it so
let's get a little bit more here
statista gave us some info in 2021 the
total revenues of the U.S government
totaled around four uh for basically
four trillion US Dollars now the problem
is
and any of you who've ever balanced the
checkbook would understand this uh when
you're uh spending money what you want
to do is spend a little bit less than
you're bringing in you bring in a
certain amount and then you go okay I
have this amount and I shouldn't spend
more than that because then I'm not
going to have money and then I'm going
to be in debt and then I have to pay
interest on it like say to China uh so
you understand that the two there was an
increase of the debt of 2.8 trillion
dollars in 2021 under Joe Biden the
democrat congress they did not have to
spend all of that money and the things
that they spent the money on actually
damaged the economy the inflation
reduction act do any of you think that
by the government taking money out of
your pocket and then somehow giving it
back to you that that caused inflation
to go down well that's that was 2021
let's jump over to 2022. here's a quote
from the center on budget and policy
priorities in the fiscal year 2022 the
federal government is estimated to spend
5.8 trillion amounting to 23.5 percent
of the nation's gross domestic product
of that 5.8 trillion over 4.8 trillion
is estimated to be financed by federal
revenues so they just keep taking more
and more of your money do you get it